still reeling from the first wave of
coronavirus
care homes fear the elderly are being
sacrificed once more
sky news can reveal plans to set up
covet units within existing care homes
which multiple providers have described
as reckless
and an attempt to keep care home
residents out of hospitals
we've obtained a copy of an email sent
to care homes in county durham
it says we are inviting expressions of
interest from care homes who are able to
offer block
booked beds for service users who test
positive for covid19
over the winter period this will apply
to both service users who are discharged
from hospital
as well as potentially service users
within the community
who require 24-hour care to avoid
hospital admittance we're also now
working with cqc
on actually actively inspecting and
designating
specific facilities the care minister
helen waitley giving evidence to a
common select committee
said specific facilities would be set up
for covered positive patients
but care england says it believes
throughout the country
only a handful of care homes will be
able to set up
entirely separate units prompting
serious concerns about the spread of the
virus
it was completely ridiculous for a
scheme to be announced at the center
and then for it to be left to the
vagaries of 300 nod local authorities
the bottom line is that we are in the
middle of a major health emergency and
what we need is strong direction
and clear leadership from the center the
government says its
absolute priority is to prevent
infections in care homes
but providers know only too well of the
dangers of the disease
in county durham providers have been
told the dedicated unit should be
self-contained with access as separate
as possible
it is also preferable if where feasible
dedicated kitchen areas and bathroom
facilities can be provided
but care homes we've spoken to say the
separation of all
covered and non-covered facilities
should be mandatory
i'm worried about what they're going to
bend to get the ends they want
we can't mix populations we can't put
our current residents at risk
unless the unit is physically removed
from the original or existing building
if it's a part of that same building i
don't think it makes a difference
because the virus is too clever and too
good at getting around
there should be a separate facility a
so-called hot home
which is just for the care of the kovid
positive think of it
as a nightingale nursing home paul
sexton says he wants to speak
out on behalf of those with loved ones
in care homes
his mother kathleen was 84 when she died
of coronavirus
in a care home in county durham in may
angry about government guidelines at the
start of the pandemic which saw
untested coveted patients discharged to
care homes
he believes the winter strategy is
flawed
it just doesn't stack up why would you
put a virus in a care home
we have two is coming well it's here and
we're doing exactly the same
as a way of warning we know we can't
contain the virus
and are we are people going to die
necessarily again it is chilling it
really is chilly
providers are asking why facilities like
the nightingale
hospitals can't be used to help care for
the elderly
the department of health and social care
says it's working with the care quality
commission
to ensure care homes which take covered
positive patients
can provide safe care lisa holland
sky news